well the best of broadway they're coming  to las vegas at the smith center and it  kicks off its long-awaited series  tomorrow night so the performance center  says it's the best broadway show yet it  all kicks off tomorrow with a trip to  the prom then other big names follow  later in the year including hamilton and  hagetown  the smith center invested in the show  hadestown which won the tony award  it's a little bit of like head  explodingly good  thank you it's called hadestown tickets  are already on sale now for a handful of  shows in the series but they're going to  go fast so swipe them up while you can  we have a link to purchase on our  website  all right